this has not been exposed anywhere in
the world no festival or anything i'm
giving you and a few other people a look
at it first
sometimes that's a better message
to a distributor
glenn how do you get paid please tell us
a couple different ways um
so
um
always a commission
um a percentage of whatever my filmmaker
makes
so there's an advance from uh the
distributor or royalties paid later on i
usually get a commission
on whatever and that's that's a
negotiable commission
uh depending on the circumstances of the
film whether it's already in a major
festival or if i'm working on it from
the beginning we can negotiate what the
commission is
often also work for a consulting fee as
well
because i spend you know most producer
reps
i would say
you know tend to throw films against the
wall see if they stick if they don't
make the deal
move on um
i deal with very much true independent
films that need a lot of hand-holding
and a lot of tender living care
and so i fashion myself as both kind of
a producer rep and a consultant so i'm
usually paid an upfront fee in addition
to my commission
really to help with the fact that i'm
going to negotiate the contract i'm
going to handle all that i'm going to
spend time with them
to make sure they understand the
industry understand the buyers
unders you know help out maybe getting
them an international sales agent so i
try to i try to fashion myself as kind
of a distribution consultant and a
producer rep are all your fees uh like
one-time fees or are there any that are
continual just one time one time one
time yes usually an upfront fee
and then um
in the way i do it i don't i don't put a
term on my my deals i'm i feel like i'm
hired for
however long it takes me to get the film
distribution
um or a festival i'm also brought on as
a festival advocate quite often that's
part of the the fee structure
is that i'm going to advocate the film
to festivals programmers i've gotten to
know over time to try and help it get
some kind of promotional boost before we
sell the film so i've gotten to know a
lot of programmers over the years so
sometimes i'm brought in pre-festival
to call programmers and just make sure
they're watching the movie
um
also to pitch it but i think the biggest
thing there is just to make sure they're
watching it um
you know if you add up the number of
you know entries into these festivals
and you look at the number of people
that are been hired to watch them it's
almost impossible right that this few
number of people are watching this
number of movies over a three-month
period so their films sometimes are not
getting watched or they're just being
watched by an intern or an underling so
i'm there to try to make sure that
someone
of significance is watching the movie
and given a chance
in addition to maybe consulting my
filmmakers on what festivals to apply to
is it right for sundance is it a south
by southwest kind of movie
um if not is it more of a heartland
seattle there's all kinds of great
festivals but you know there are
different festivals of different
strategies so
i'm here for that you know kind of in
addition to everything else have you
ever had filmmakers say skip the
festivals i i i won't get into this one
and i won't get into that one and these
other ones i don't care as much about
absolutely um
and you know from an advisory point of
view i've even said that too to some
people that
um
your film isn't right it's commercial um
it's um you know if you have a family
movie right um
sundance doesn't take a lot of family
films and they have they i mean they
might have a section where they take
like one or two really you know big
family films but they're not going to
take small kind of dog or pony movies
right those kind of movies
um aren't right for festivals
um
horror films you know in general
um of a certain level don't there's a
horror audience out there that doesn't
really require kind of lift of a film
festival to to get it
out there
and to a certain degree
festivals really only add so much value
these days to a film festival and the
real value at least pre-covid
for me for of sundance and south by and
tribeca
those are festivals that are attended
by buyers
and so they're in a room
they're feeling the audience watch the
movie
um
it's the only place where distributors
make mistakes right where they where
they like
they get a feeling like okay let's go
bid on the movie off this feeling they
have in the theater
um they're never gonna have that feeling
when they're watching the film on their
cell phone while they're driving or or
however they're they're watching your
movie right
it's um so those festivals in particular
have that in addition to some branding
value they also had the value of having
the people there watching the movie
there's another
several thousand film festivals in north
america that buyers just don't go to
really great festivals um
and maybe one or two show up because
they're on a panel or something but
they're not flocking there to watch the
content to see if there's films to buy
they know that at some point those films
will eventually get to them and they'll
be able to watch it in their office it's
not worth flying all over the country to
see these to these festivals
um
and
the so the value to distribute the value
there is maybe if we have a film that's
not right for sundance didn't get
tribeca et cetera but it goes to seattle
then we're going to the distributor
saying hey here's this great movie and
it just premiered in seattle
check it out and you pitch the movie and
then they watch it and take now now the
fact that it's in seattle
goes in one ear and out the other right
it's not a heavy consideration for them
like oh wow i played seattle not the one
with flux i'm going to get all kinds of
hate mail about seattle but seattle is a
great festival but the buyers just
aren't there and so the distributors are
going to watch it on vimeo at that point
or blu-ray
um
so
um
there's just there's just marginal value
for festivals at that point but there's
lots of other good reasons to go to
festivals other than will it get
distribution because of them
you know
it's the best experience
you have with the film usually
experience it with an audience it's
better than theatrical per se
where it's which is you know it's kind
of cold there's not like a ready willing
audience uh you go to the limly and
you're there's five seats filled and
this doesn't have the same
impact as a as a festival screening
where people are there to you know to
purposefully enjoy a film like they
really want to enjoy it
and
other reasons are
to get feedback from fellow filmmakers
to see other people's films to meet
other people you might work with in the
future
to maybe meet someone who wants to
invest in your next movie
there's all sorts of good things that
come out of festivals but really for
setting up distribution there's it's
really
minimal what what they what they provide
for that um
so when i'm talking to filmmakers
i have to kind of deal with their
expectations of what they want to do
and give advice on like how to proceed
strategically to get the film the best
possible position
and usually i'm going to save it's not a
sundance or a south buyer tribeca kind
of film we can go for festivals and do
that but at any time if you get tired of
that
and you're like we haven't gotten a
festival can we go right to buyers we
can because
it's only providing a little bit of
color to the fact that you've got a good
film already in my view
um
so and so when filmmakers do come to me
and say
let's just go straight to buyers no
problem um
really no problem at all um
it's to a certain degree too um
some
um
i i've had you know there are places
like there's some streamer a couple of
streamers
um
that i've approached the films
before and they once a film's in a
festival they've already kind of
looked at it
not not that they've seen the film but
they've kind of digested what it is
and made an assessment
um
[Music]
purely off of an image
and a synopsis
we want to check that out or we don't
um there's a lot they don't
so i've had a little bit more success
with some films especially documentaries
um if i'm going to them without anything
and saying hey this has not been exposed
anywhere in the world
no festival or anything i'm giving you
and a few other people a look at it
first
sometimes that's a better message um to
a distributor
than hey we played seattle
because sometimes i'll get yeah we
looked we saw it in the listings not for
us you know you'll get sometimes then
i've got to beg and play them to watch
it and give it another chance so
um
yeah it's uh
you know
at the same time though
lots of filmmakers just want to play
festivals right they just that's just a
thing and very understandably there's a
lot of great stuff about it so
you know the i'm here to advise on
strategy and then once we've decided
with the filmmaker what to do then i'll
implement it whatever kind of whatever
they want to do
so they want to play festivals do they
also want to attend or some are okay
getting into these bigger festivals and
not going
yeah you get different most i find want
to attend i remember talking pre-covet
again but when you could but um
most i find want to attend occasionally
i'll find someone who doesn't really
care about going
um but overwhelming 90 i think want to
go and have the experience of of the
crowd and and all the things that you
get out of the film festival
yeah sure q a yeah those are great yeah
absolutely right feeling the energy yeah
what red flag should a filmmaker look
for if they are considering hiring a
producer rep
well
um
so i would say
look at all their go to imdb
look at their history of all the films
that they've sold um
call those filmmakers
um if you know dig in find a website
address you know if it's not readily
available get to those people and and
call them
and see what kind of experience they had
i imagine that all producer reps and
distributors and sales agents all have
people that don't like them
[Music]
but
hopefully you find someone that's got
more people that like them that don't
like them
um
i think um
i think you know when i when i pitch
myself for and i'm never really
cognizant of like who else they're
looking at like i don't have a sense of
my competition that way it's never like
me against the same three guys for a
film it just doesn't it's it's fairly um
i find that
i think most films that i talk to about
repping their films
um
aren't really considering many other
options
um i that's the sense i get i don't
really ask them about it or really care
um
but um
i i can say this so i know when i
decided to get into the business
i was working for an international sales
agent at the time
and
looking around the landscape i felt like
there was a need for someone to do what
i do
a little bit more deeply than i felt
like other producer reps were doing it
like i kind of alluded to before there's
a lot of just kind of
okay toss it to the wall
if none of these 10 distributors want it
moving on you know
which leaves everybody empty and and so
i really try to do i i try to do the job
of making sure i understand the full
distribution landscape
who are the best possible options for
this film if none of them
want it what are the possible second
tier options for them to do
i also have my own tricks of the trade
if something were to fall to
self-distribution
per se
what's the what are the best practices
there who's the best aggregator to use
you know those situations so i'm i'm
trying to i'm trying to provide a full
kind of consulting service around what i
do as opposed to that
so i i think that
um when you're looking for a producer
rep it's kind of it's kind of like
references
you know do you like the films they've
sold
in the past is your film feel like a fit
um
you know have they made deals you know
can you can they point to films that
have had had deals with
netflix and hulu and showtime and hbo
and
and ifc etc
um
but yeah
it's funny i should probably take
another look at the at the landscape of
producer reps out there besides myself
and see what options people have to
to um
maybe give a fuller answer on that but
yeah to a certain degree i think that's
probably the
way to go about it